if there's anybody approximating a king
maker remaining in the republican party
to some degree
it is actually 78 year old republican
senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell and love him or hate him
and i don't like the guy
he has been one of the most effective
republicans in the last decade at just
getting things done when republicans
want to do something
and blocking democrats from doing things
when republicans don't want them doing
things the merrick garland
supreme court nomination certainly comes
to mind and immediately following joe
biden's formal electoral
electoral college win on monday where
each state's electors
voted and confirmed that indeed joe
biden has 270 electoral votes
mitch mcconnell acknowledged joe biden's
win and congratulated
joe biden now this is not praise of
mitch mcconnell mitch mcconnell
avoided acknowledging that joe biden won
for five weeks after the election
even when it was obvious that joe biden
had won this is not about mitch
mcconnell being a good guy
it's once again even someone as horrible
as mitch mcconnell
as unwilling to admit what is there and
plain to see as mitch mcconnell
is saying joe biden won effectively
ending
any remote possibility that the
republican party would insist
that joe biden didn't really win here is
mitch mcconnell yesterday
on the floor of the u.s senate take a
listen but our system of government
has processes to determine who will be
sworn in
on january the 20th the electoral
college
has spoken so today i want to
congratulate president-elect joe biden
the president-elect is no stranger to
the senate
he's devoted himself to public service
for many years
i also want to congratulate the vice
president-elect our colleague from
california senator harris
beyond our differences all americans can
take pride that our nation has a female
vice president-elect
for the very first time i look forward
to finishing out the next 36 days strong
with president trump
our nation needs us to add another
bipartisan chapter
to this record of achievement so this is
important for a few reasons
number one this signals that there's
really nothing left for trump i mean
truly nothing to try
to steal this election now i know that
the q anon people
and the cultists and even trump himself
and you know kaylee mcinanny as we saw
earlier
they're going to continue acting as if
there's more to do maybe jenna ellis is
going to if she's recovered from
coronavirus
they're going to keep going but when
even the senate majority
on january 6 who do you think is going
to interfere
with joe biden officially being a
president-elect
in terms of congress accepting the votes
it would be members of the republican
party in the house and senate and the
senate majority leader here has said
congratulations to joe biden so
it signals the the emptying of the bag
of tricks so to speak
but secondly this is also relevant and
important for people who were
dreaming of something to happen
uh sometime between now and the
inauguration that would slow down or
prevent joe biden swearing in
when mitch mcconnell acknowledges the
president-elect
it really makes that dream or really
it's a nightmare
it makes it all but an impossibility and
we also learned that mitch mcconnell and
joe biden spoke
after this congratulations here's joe
biden briefly speaking to the media
yesterday telling us how that call with
mitch mcconnell went
i had a good conversation with mitch
mcconnell today
he talked to him i called him to thank
him for the congratulations
told him although we disagree on a lot
of things those things we can work
together on
we've always been struggling on one
another and uh
we agreed we get together sooner than
later
and i'm looking forward to working with
them i just want to know i spoke with
them
i've been calling other members i spoke
with some other members as well there's
about a dozen calling
and as i kick them off i'll tell you who
i've spoken to okay
thank you so that's straightforward and
to the point there so
slowly but surely all of the remaining
eyes are dotted and t's are crossed
to nobody's surprise except for the
millions of trump cultists who thought
that this might go some other way
now my only concern about what joe biden
said continues to be the same one i've
had from before the election
i hope that joe biden is merely paying
lip service
to the idea of getting things done with
mitch mcconnell because
it would be cartoonishly naive
to think that this republican party
is going to work with you on anything
and as i've said before
the only way you would get this
republican party to work with you on
anything there's there's two scenarios
in which this republican party might
help you one is
if they determine that getting in the
way of what you're working on
would actually hurt them electorally
like if you if they
determine imagine that there's no
stimulus passed now and biden gets to
oversee a second stimulus
if republicans determine that not doing
a second stimulus is bad for them
they might actually come to the table
with joe biden but they would still try
to make it mostly for corporations
uh and not really for for individuals
the second scenario
where republicans would work with joe
biden or work with democrats in general
is if joe biden and democrats are
willing to accept
such outrageous compromise to get
republicans on board
that it becomes almost like a peric
victory where it's a victory on paper
but you may actually be doing
more harm than good in so working with
these republicans so
my concern continues to be the naivete
if joe biden
really thinks he's going to work with
these people he's not now
very quickly mitch mcconnell became
enemy number one of the trump cult we'll
do more about this later but just one
example
for you here this is a video clip of
trump sycophant charlie kirk
actually saying that this might be mitch
mcconnell ruining the chances in georgia
of the republican candidates by
acknowledging that joe biden won
and so if mitch mcconnell wants to wake
up on january
6 and
be met with two of his senate candidates
all of a sudden trailing in georgia
keep talking like this go out of your
way to use the term
congratulate
if he had to and was getting pressure he
could have at the very most
today i will recognize i probably would
have taken exception with that
but the term congratulations inherently
means that you are applauding and
recognizing
an achievement of success
when do you use congratulations in your
life
when people attain athletic
accomplishments when people get married
engaged
you typically don't use the term
congratulations
when someone just stole a bank i love
that
charlie going full on he's charlie
doesn't even stop at robbing a bank
he says it's like stealing the entire
bank just picking up the whole bank and
taking it really fascinating stuff
so this is a similar situation
to some trumpists who now think fox news
is liberal and part of the problem the
idea
that someone as wretchedly conservative
as mitch mcconnell
might not be a strong enough right
winger just shows you how extreme the
trump cult has become
but understand that part of this is
calculation by mitch
mitch knows they don't have the votes to
actually stop
joe biden from being president they he
knows they can't do anything
and mitch mcconnell wants to get back to
the standard partisan bickering and
republican obstruction
of democrats as soon as possible and so
what mitch mcconnell is effectively
doing here is kind of ripping the
band-aid
off now and getting people back to
reality
sooner get republicans back to being
united about
you know the deficit and stopping
anything democrats want to do so i
i actually looking at it from the
standpoint of mitch mcconnell
i think what he's doing here actually
makes perfect sense it obviously makes
sense based on the votes biden won and
we knew that five weeks ago
but i think it also even is the right
strategy if your goal is
reunite the republican party and let's
get back to stopping joe biden from
doing a damn thing and they may well
succeed at it one of our sponsors today
is magic spoon
the reason i'm such a fan of magic spoon
is they allow me to enjoy the delicious
breakfast cereals i loved as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary cereals that we all
know
but each serving of magic spoon has no
sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money
if you don't love it no questions asked
go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video